dirigé par fgny Prigogine le groupe
paramilitaire russe Wagner avait ses
dernières années un terrain de chasse
favori c'est l'Afrique continent où ces
mercenaires seraient aujourd'hui
présents dans une quinzaine de pays
formation de l'armée et surtout de la
garde présidentielle en Centrafrique
répression des manifestations anti LB
chiro Soudan de l'insurrection au
Mozambique ou encore livraison d'armes
et combat avec l'armée du maréchal
aftaran Libye ses missions varient d'un
pays à l'autre
le modèle économique africain de Wagner
lui est toujours le même c'est la
prédation des ressources locales en
échange de ses services comme au Mali et
en Centrafrique où le groupe a fait main
basse sur plusieurs mines d'or du pays à
la clé une immense manne financière un
chiffrable mais indispensables pour
financer les opérations de ces derniers
mois en Ukraine et surtout bien payé ses
hommes
la question désormais la mutinerie
avortée de ces derniers jours va-t-elle
pousser des pays à chasser Wagner de
leur territoire et ainsi le privé d'une
bonne partie de son financement pour la
chef de la diplomatie française
Catherine colonnat il faut encore
attendre je pense qu'il est trop tôt
pour tirer l'ensemble des conclusions de
ces événements et sur place en Russie et
autour de la Russie et certainement en
Afrique aussi mais cela justifie toute
notre attention nous continuerons d'être
extrêmement attentif et vigilant sur les
activités de Wagner à ce stade aucun
pays africain accueillant Wagner sur son
sol n'a encore exprimé le souhait de
voir ces mercenaires plier bagages